is your life um similar in a sense to a
guy like dan bilzerian i mean he's a
very like he's far more public and he's
got a bigger reach with the instagram
thing and he made that happen a number
of years ago but i mean
you're a guy that i can reach out to
like i've got you on whatsapp but you
know i can reach out to you and say hey
you know what are you up to sort of
thing
but i feel like your life is like his
but
i don't even know if it's at another
level like i feel like you guys live
better you know to some regard because
the way that you have no apologies to
anything in a different sort of way
there's a debate with dan bilzerian
there's a debate whether he was legit
whether he's not whether it's dad's
money whether he's do you think he's
rich himself
i
hoped he was for a very long time but
finding out that when all these stories
came out you know that he's a big fake
but you know people have written
[ __ ] about me too so i did my i did
my research and when it all came out it
was fake it kind of upset me because i
feel like i like people like him
existing
to give that message to you know what i
live how i want i [ __ ] who i want i'm
not going to get tied down i'm not going
to get divorce rate i just put my dick
in whichever model i like and everyone
could leave me alone and i don't
apologize i like that being broadcast to
the world because i actually think it's
a healthy message for a lot of young men
to hear and it's it's something that a
lot of young men need to know as
possible so it's not like me finding out
santa wasn't real because i don't
[ __ ] idolize him i don't idolize
anybody i'm a self-made man i live in in
my own world but at my level and my
brother's level you have to understand
i've met women and [ __ ] women who have
been to his house who have been to his
parties so i know his setup his setup is
he contacts the model agencies they all
sign ndas
they shouldn't she shouldn't have spoke
to me i'm not gonna name dropper they
all sign ndas uh they get an allowance
they get their flights paid for
you can't rely on a woman signing an nda
to keep your mouth shut exactly exactly
clearly obviously not they get an
allowance a weekly expenditure now he
doesn't actually pay them for sex but
they're flown in they're paid for their
uh you know they're giving money to hang
out with him and he does [ __ ] some of
them now that's very different from my
setup
typically my setup was for many many
years i would approach women and meet
them and seduce them in the
old-fashioned way and within a few
months they were earning money for me to
make me richer either on webcam or a
platform like only fans or something
like that so i see myself on a higher
level because i distinguish the
difference between being a customer and
being a provider of the of the service
you know i'm the guy who gets money
because he has women not the guy who
spends his money to get women near him
uh but i liked the message he was he was
spreading out there is my life similar
to his
i don't know he is the king of instagram
good for him i mean he's a he's a big
big boy on instagram i'm about 300 and
something thousand followers
each time i get new cars etc it jumps by
10 15 000.
i will climb up there eventually but
that's not why i'm doing it
i don't post as often as i should i
don't take my instagram as serious as i
could a lot of the fun things i do
aren't on my instagram if i took it more
seriously i think i could be bigger but
my life is certainly amazing i haven't
listened
how do you how do you distinguish what
part of your life gets to be shown on
instagram versus what you reserve
to be kept private
well it's all down to i don't care about
my instagram audience for me it's how
much trouble is this going to cause me
so in the last episode with other women
or with the authorities or
no but in general but usually with other
women with people i mean there's last
episode of take confidential mind of my
brother's kind of youtube vlog where we
just sometimes whip out our phones when
we're doing [ __ ] and we edit the footage
together i was on a camping trip we
rented these big tents in the in the
transylvanian mountains kind of glamping
more than camping but i was with three
different women
now all the women who know me know who
these three are and after that episode
was released it was all oh why didn't i
get invited why didn't you bring me on
it because you don't like her and she
doesn't like her and it's chess and it's
politics and it gets me in trouble
so that's what i think about before i
post things on social media i don't care
about my audience and what they'd like
to see i think is this going to get me
in trouble
is this going to cause me unnecessary
headache and unnecessary grief you know
i want to keep my life happy so i'm
happy having all the pictures of the
women all the pictures of me partnering
with girls in my phone and i don't need
to show anybody
i just don't like it's not it's not why
i do it do you think that there's a
chunk of the
guys out there that
purport to hold out to the public that
their authorities on women in dating
that are full of crap that are i think
ah
this is a this is a slippery slope i'm
going to go down but i think man slide
down yeah man there are you know let's
go down the road
there are people
who i think can teach certain things to
different calibers of men
but in terms of just having it
nailed in terms of what i refer to as
living in god mode like i have i can't
have as much sex per day as the number
of really beautiful women who want to
have sex with me i don't have that many
hours because i'm busy driving supercars
and doing other [ __ ] this is why i
describe my life as god mode it's
unlimited resources essentially
and i think it's very easy to
on the internet because so many men are
in a horrible position right now so many
men are living lives where they're
failing with women they're failing on
the sexual battlefield they're failing
in the sexual marketplace they have no
clue that it's very easy to be a
pretender i mean i'm a martial artist i
come from a kickboxing background and
there are some gyms especially in the
united states they're referred to as
mcdojos when someone doesn't know how to
fight doesn't know karate doesn't know
kickboxing doesn't know taekwondo but
he's teaching other people how to fight
and you know because it's very cool to
have men look up to you be like yeah
this guy's a badass they don't want to
put in the years of hard training they
don't want to do the actual work they
just want people to admire them as some
sort of authority on something that's
badass and open people's ass and having
sex with a bunch of beautiful women is a
badass thing to do
and on twitter it's very very easy i
mean don't even get me started on
anonymous accounts rivolino like
what are you doing
matt yeah wrote the mask slips
occasionally he wants bragged about
having sex with seven different women in
five day in five years
the mask slipped off
and you saw for a second underneath
seven in five years i've literally done
seven
in in 48 hour periods of time and and
for for him to be an authority that
people listen to it just goes to show
this the state of men
as a whole is is is lost it's it's
terrible for these people to be
authorities they're all fake ninety
percent
ninety percent ninety percent
the guys who claim to sleep with
beautiful women in bed beautiful women
ninety percent now there are people like
rolo tomasi who and rolo talks [ __ ]
about me sometimes but you know let me
tell you something i have friends who
would be like i was married and i read
his book and his book saved my life i
haven't read rollers but i've read one
actually on audiobook but i don't need
the work of roller tomassi but when
people who i respect say yeah his work
saved my life i mean i'm like you know
what cool that roller guy obviously
knows something but rolo doesn't run
around saying i [ __ ] all the [ __ ]
this is why i don't i don't have
anything really bad to say about him but
loads of guys claim that they do [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] and no one shows receipts
no one is like here are all the women
i'm sleeping with i mean you just pulled
up one of my tweets
i i used to run that anonymous account
where every day i was tweeting the women
i slept with yeah that was a very small
following there too and i was privileged
enough to see all of that
i've still got that on yeah i've still
got that i run an instagram account now
that has no followers and it's private
but each time i sleep with a new woman
starting at this year i just upload a
picture of her for myself because it
makes me happy to see it
and when you're playing at my level
ninety percent of the guys out there
claiming to date women sleep with women
meet women pull women they're all fake
no one's showing their cards no one's
showing their
their uh me and my brother had the
analogy we're saying we're fishermen and
we all talked about fishing all day long
me and andrew are the guys on instagram
with our huge catches weighing them
saying this is my fish this is my fish
everyone just talks about fishing all
day where's everyone's [ __ ] fish
where are the pictures where's the
evidence you know it's it's it's
mind-blowing that these guys still
can have such a large audience showing
zero receipts zero yeah even one anon
accounts are
dangerous the worst uh often quite
deceptive i mean why are they hiding you
know why can't we see you know what's
going on you see it in all kinds of
different genres out there it's not just
in spaces like this too right i mean you
see it everywhere
i mean you know you know the answer
already you know the answer why can't we
see them because what they are saying
they do and what they claim to have
doesn't exist a limitable man is uh tell
your son this is is world renowned for
his i've been blocked by a lot of those
guys yeah i've been talking about lions
guys because i called them out on their
[ __ ] yeah not as much as you guys i mean
you guys you guys destroyed that guy
with with like one week of material i
think right yeah yeah
the jordy guy no tell your son this guy
that guy
yeah because he was chasing one of the
girls that was in your cam studio or
something was it was that majority guy
no well that's that's it's both of them
so
and you know there's a few names there's
ah man
i'm not gonna do it i'm not gonna do it
but very recently a couple months ago
one of these i'm a playboy i'm this i'm
that who doesn't tell anyone his real
identity with the exact same email
address he uses on his uh
with the exact same email address he
uses on his his mailing list etc had
signed up to an oni fans account was
tipping one of my girls money so you
know who you are my friend this beers
this beer is on you i guess thank you
very much but uh you need to get off the
internet telling men that you know how
to get laid because i've read your
messages and they're really [ __ ] sad
they're really sad rich you know what
you know what
do i say his name do i just tell you you
know what just just uh send it over to
me on the whatsapp you know i will i
will i will do it
because now i gotta know let's give a
woman give me like give me give it three
things ask your next next question i'll
track it down
you